so here's a nice calculus question what
is the integral from 0 to 100 of e to
the power of x minus 4 of X DX
the floor of X is the largest integer
that's less than or equal to X
so here's how we can work it out let's
graph x minus floor of x
notice we have a periodic function
now let's take a look at one of these
intervals say 0 to 1 the floor of X is
equal to zero so x minus floor of X is
equal to X and this repeats for every
one of the 100 intervals so this
original integral is equal to 100
multiplied by the integral from 0 to 1
of e to the power of x minus floor of X
this is equal to 100 multiplied by the
integral from 0 to 1 of e to the X DX so
this is very straightforward we evaluate
this and now this simplifies to be 100
multiplied by the quantity e minus one
and that's the answer